boy I gotta join the left because that's
why I take it to making money yeah
that's their next ticket that's their
next check and they they the funny thing
is the left argues it's the right that
does that and I'm like okay
name me uh
uh any anyone who was a staunch leftist
who was a die-hard liberal advocating
and yelling Obama who is now coming out
and going Trump Maga 2024 right there
there are some you could probably
mention however if you take a look at
the people they tend to name Dave Rubin
Dave Rubin was never like holding up big
Obama signs he was just a default
liberal he got into politics said hey
wait a minute I didn't know that and now
he is where he is he's like kind of
libertarian they say he was he's
grifting you know because he's been left
it's like no no no you don't understand
the average person I think Breitbart
called them default liberal yeah they
consume news from CNN and from The New
York Times they assume it's true and
then they're liberal because of it then
when they start actually digging in and
researching they're like hey wait that
was a lie that doesn't make them
conservative it just means that they
know what's going on in the world